petit escargot porte sur son dos c'est
une comptine bien connue des petits et
des grands mais avec quelque chose en
plus le langage des signes
véronique cole a fait découvrir aux
enfants et à leurs parents la langue des
signes française un autre mode de
communication accessible aux plus jeunes
c'est avec des mots signés issus de la
langue des signes française pour pouvoir
accompagner les mots parlés et enrichir
le lexique de communication va dire pour
l'enfant de façon à ce que l'enfant
puisse aussi reprendre les signes en
terme de mouvements et de gestuelle pour
pouvoir les utiliser dans son expression
au jour tout le monde
c'est l'heure de se lever
elmer l'éléphant multicolores ou boucles
d'or des histoires simples qui
permettent aux enfants de 6 mois à 4 ans
de s'identifier
donc je vais prendre en fait des albums
jeunesse de la vie quotidienne avec eux
le doudou avec eux manger boire pour
pouvoir donner du vocabulaire de base et
des signes et de la gestuelle du de la
vie quotidienne prochaine séance prévue
le samedi 5 mai à la médiathèque du
château de plaisir un moment de partage
où les grands apprennent presque autant
que les petits